Okay,
so the question is that the totalitarian
forms that we've seen primarily in the
past have been male and,
but maybe we're seeing something
different now.
I really don't think it's different.
I think it's.
It's out of the common kind that's
expanded in its dominion,
so you imagine that there's an essential
feminine pathology just as there is an
essential masculine pathology and the
essential feminine pathology.
Freud mapped out.
It's the eternal mother and the mother
is the mother that gets too close to her
children.
Right,
and intermingles herself with them too,
too great.
A degree that in her attempts to protect
them undermines them fatally,
and so there's a classic representation
of the feminine in the West and the
classic representation is married and
here,
here's one of the representations.
It's lovely and it's derived at least in
part from the story of Mary and the
snake in the garden of Eden,
and so Mary has her foot on a serpent
and she's holding Christ off to the side
like this.
Well,
that's exactly what mothers have always
done.
It's a biological portrait of human
women is they hold their infants out of
the reach of the terrible Serpentine
Predator.
Obviously that's what we do.
Well,
that's fine,
but adults aren't infants and neither
are children and if you treat them like
they are,
you undermine them,
you,
you pathologize them,
you turn them into old infants.
That's an ugly thing and that's the
Freudian nightmare.
You know,
in,
in this happens in therapy very
frequently.
I mean you can be tangled into a
terrible relationship with your father
that's often either because he was
absent or abusive or tyrannical,
something like that,
but that standard pathology with mom is,
she did everything for you.
Well,
what's left for you to do nothing
including never leaving.
Right?
And that's the motivation.
You know,
for the woman who's nothing but
protective mother,
there's no role outside of nurturing,
of nurturing,
nurturing,
of nurturance,
of infants,
of nurture,
of infants.
Well,
you just keep them.
Infants,
they'll never leave.
Am I kill you in night in your sleep?
But they'll never leave.
Sure,
sure.
I mean,
it's so comical watching the feminist
postmodernists in particular rattle on
about the absence of gender reality and
act out the archetipal devouring mother
at exactly the same time for them,
for them.
The world is divided into predators and
infants and the predators are evil and
need to be stopped and the infants need
to be cared for.
Well,
that's what the mother does,
but adults are not infants
and all you do is destroy them when you
treat them that way,
especially when they're adolescents and
just starting to develop.
Now there's.
There's a rule that I attempted to abide
by when I had small children and the
rule was don't do anything for your
children that they can do themselves and
it's annoying that rule because it takes
you like 15 seconds to to dress a two
year old,
but you'll let that two year old dress
himself.
It's like 15 minutes or 20 minutes or
half an hour.
You chase them around the house,
but if you let them learn to dress
themselves,
then you don't have to dress themselves
any direct,
dress them anymore and they can do it,
and you do that with setting the table
and you do that with everything.
It's like,
no,
it's okay.
You do that now while I care for you so
much.
Let me do that for you.
It's like,
I don't care for you at all when I say
that I don't care for you at all.
I'm going to stop doing everything I
possibly can for you as rapidly as I
possibly can say,
well,
that's great.
That's how you work in an old age home.
Do not do anything for the inhabitants
that they can do themselves because you
robbed them of the last vestiges of
their independence.
Right?
It's what you do when you're a manager.
If you're a good manager,
you make yourself superfluous by
extending autonomy and independence to
the people that you manage so that they
can take over the whole job.
You don't do that by doing everything
for people and you certainly don't do
that by dividing the world
architecturally and uncritically into
predators.
Those who have more and victims,
infants,
those who have nothing and acting like
all you can ever do is protect them.
You don't protect,
first of all,
you can't protect people.
You can only make them strong.
That's it.
You cannot protect them.
You can make them strong and then they
can predict themselves,
but then they don't need you.
Right,
and there's the underground pathological
element of the devouring mother.
It's like,
never leave me.
Here's the deal.
I'll do everything for you.
You just never leave.
Right.
That's sleeping with your mother,
right?
That's the Friday a nightmare,
You don't invite your child into your
bed,
right.
You distinguished between them and you.
You distinguish between them and your
husband and you facilitate their
independence.
A part of the reason why it's useful to
have a mother and a father is because
the mother has to fall insanely in love
with the infant or she'd throw it out
the window,
right?
Because they're.
They're insanely demanding and they're
always right.
Right.
Because the right way to treat an
infant,
especially before nine months,
is I'll do everything for you and you're
always right in your needs.
Take priority over everyone's one else's
and anybody that threatens you is
terrible.
Exactly right,
but after once the kid is ambulatory and
starting to be independent,
that's the wrong attitude.
The attitude then is no get the hell on
with it.
And men who are less prone to negative
emotion and less compassionate are much
better at fostering kind of
independence.
And so it's usually then when they step
into the family and start playing with
the kids rough and tumble play and
pushing them forward and saying,
you know,
get on with it.
You can do it,
you can do it at home.
It's very hard for a mother to play both
those rules because she has to fall so
in love with her infant that it's
difficult for her to be universal
caregiver and disciplinarian at the same
time,
you know,
because the roles are the roles run
contrary to one another.
So now women have entered the political
sphere right on Mohs,
and so they're going to bring their
essential nature with them all the while
saying,
there's no such thing as essential
nature.
It's like,
yeah,
there is.